welcome to great america where they're
striving every day to make America great
again Rob and I just finished the 40
holographic Mass Effect ride Rob would
you think yeah we're in santa clara uh
this is mass effect Mary it was pretty
cool you know I had my doubts you know
you think on a nice day you're in a
theater seems a lot but the ride itself
is pretty cool it's for dimension so
that's 3d that's uh that's jolting back
and forward right and I don't if you
notice is there are some knobs like in
my upper butt and they like my thighs
that's the extra d that's well there's
more d Mary and not only did they do
they have the moving seats and stuff but
they also have spray hitting you and the
head smells what is mass effect smell
like rum it's a mixture of dirt and Buck
oh just like a recap of like what
actually happens in the ride is you know
there's an actor right in front and he
basically leads you on a journey I would
say the timeframe takes place at the
beginning of mass effect 3 so you get
into a ship and you they're taking you
to new earth which is the ride Mass
Effect newer and they're letting you
have a timeshare there which is really
nice of them they look part of the joke
that you're you can like join in a
timeshare and yea which was kind of
interesting to see no this is a
family-friendly ride and as we all know
mass effect 3 was not the funniest
brightest game while a lot of death the
dark damn mass genocide but this is a
funny ride like the kind of tried to
make it light-hearted and rush they
could exactly so like there's a part
where you are
arriving to this planet Terra Nova which
is like new earth I guess and he's like
yeah that's a great place you know your
time should open up let's talk to so and
so and it cuts to this video of a guy
going oh there's def everywhere any to
go huh that's interesting and then you
have to continue you kind of crash land
you're in a new ship you see all these
you know icons from the trilogy so you
see liara you see garrus of course they
have a lot of flashbacks to the game a
lot of characters that you guys will
remember even like the bugs or so stuff
that you probably remember from the
environments and stuff and they're
coming out spitting at you and freaking
you out and trying to eat the host yeah
so that's like the biggest 4d moment was
when fireflies kind of like fly by you
and that's where you get the air pockets
and your face and your arms and then
this huge arachnid kind of mother boss
sees you in sleep sprays water that's
where you get a splash ball so they take
over the ship and then after they do
that you're kind of like stuck on this
huge rider you're taking over and you're
trying to destroy everything that's kind
of trying to kill the people in this
environment right so I've ending of
course what better villain then off see
the Reaper so a huge Reaper Walker drops
out of the sky and then the rest of the
ride is basically you kind of battling
that and there were some really cool
actually some really cool moments so
there's like you know there's gassing
and flare flying around this one moment
and like I said it's going like yeah and
then like you two guys just blows up in
his face is a cool you're like honestly
he's having more fun than you are yeah
which is important it was fun it was a
fun experience like obviously these
types of things are really out there but
it's fun to enjoy mass effect in a
different environment
different experience and in a world
where you feel like everyone is along
for the ride with you you and you kind
of help sell the fact that you're there
and you're just enjoying this world that
you sent so many hours playing so that
makes it really cool and that's really
awesome it's a nice new addition to
great america so not too bad not too bad
not too bad at all and just you guys
know yeah it's a mass effect smells like
dirt and bugs